>> Okay, Michael, so here's the quiz. Are you ready?
>> Sure.
>> Okay, so here's what's going on. I have copied over our little grid world
over here twice. So it's the same grid world except I have changed the rewards
that you will receive in all of the states other than the two absorbing states.
So for the top one you get a reward of plus two. In every single
state, except for the absorbing states, and in the bottom one you receive a
reward of minus two in every single state but the absorbing states, got it?
>> Interesting.
>> So, what I'm going to want you to do is, I'm going to want
you to fill in for these boxes that I've indicated, these same four boxes in
the top and the bottom, whether you should go up, down, left or right. So
enter into each one of them either Up U, D down, R right, L left,
okay?
>> Yeah, I appreciate you making the numbers nice and big, because I was
worried you're going to say something like minus 0.13. But this, this I think.
>> I can do that.
>> No, no, no, that wasn't a suggestion. Yeah, let's go with the plus two and
minus two. I feel like there's a better chance I might be able to get it.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, so you think you got the what we're trying to do here?
>> I do. Now just to, just to keep, just to make sure that I'm there,
the plus one and the minus one end the game,
and there's no more reward after that, it's like zero forever.
>> Yep.
>> And the other things, the blueish rewards, I would get them.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Continually until a state is reached.
>> Right, exactly.
>> Where the game ends, okay Yeah. No, that's, that's, that's cool.
>> Okay, cool. Alright so go.